(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
IF ONLY THERE WAS A VIDEO
UPLOADING APP THAT ALLOWED
PEOPLE TO MIMIC WHAT CERTAIN
PEOPLE BE LIKE IN SIX-SECOND
INCREMENTS.
WHAT'S THAT, YOU SAY?
THERE IS?
THE "BLOBBITY BLOBBITY BE LIKE"
TREND ON VINE IS PRETTY MUCH
UBIQUITOUS, SO COMEDIANS, I'M
GOING TO SHOW YOU A THUMBNAIL
OF A VINE AND GIVE YOU TWO
OPTIONS.
YOU HAVE TO GUESS WHICH ONE IS
BE LIKE IS RIGHT, OKAY?
HERE WE GO, FIRST ONE, FIRST
ONE.
ROB HUEBEL?
>> GIRL SEEING HER BESTIE BE
LIKE.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> WHEN A GIRL SEE HER BESTIE,
SHE BE LIKE--
(SCREAMING)
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> IT'S TRUE, IT'S 100% TRUE.
>> Chris: IS THIS TRUE?
>> LENNON AND I ARE...
(SCREAMING)
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
LENNON.
>> RATCHET GIRLS IN CLASS BE
LIKE.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> OH, MY GOD.
I HATE THIS CLASS.
WHAT HER WORD?
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> OH, MAN.
>> Chris: ALL THOSE RATCHET
GIRLS.
>> SHE TOOK US ON A REAL
EMOTIONAL JOURNEY IN THAT VINE,
DIDN'T SHE?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: THERE WAS AN ARC.
IT WAS WELL DONE.
>> YEAH.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE, NEXT ONE:
YES, JESSICA.
>> CHICKS TAKING SELFIES BE
LIKE.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> UNICORNS BE LIKE...
(LAUGHTER)
>> NO!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)